The talk is revolutionizing customer
engagement through Graph Rock systems.
We were having a conversation earlier,
which actually led out of a podcast that
Andreas you had been featured in. Um
understanding what is happening now in
enterprise
uh in terms of introduction of semantic
layer. And what does this mean to
reconcile previous practices with what
we need to move forward toward
understanding actually the knowledge
that is that is in
uh being operated on.
Um so again, please join me in welcoming
Andreas.
>> [applause]
>> Thank you. Um maybe we Can we remove
this little
stop sharing, please? Thank you.
Excellent. Thanks a lot. Yeah, okay.
Thanks for joining.
Uh we'll talk about uh
how to use Graph Rock systems uh when
customer engagement should get increased
or improved.
Uh so it's a use case. We believe uh
it's a very important use case on top of
Graph Rock systems.
And let me show you a little bit why uh
this is important and how that could uh
yeah, work in in an environment um
where a lot of data is around about uh
uh products and uh
content about
technical documentation, for instance.
And users try to find their way uh
through this landscape at heterogeneous
landscape.
Uh and start uh yeah, see a bit of a
disconnectedness, typically.
So customer journeys can be quite
painful.
Uh especially when it comes to complex
products.
And so, the question is how can we as a
craft community address that? And yeah,
this is the talk
I will now present in the next 20
minutes.
Before I come to the details, just a
quick
announcement. As probably some of you
have seen, there's an interesting merger
that has happened in the past few weeks.
It's a new
company now called Craftwise.
Fusing Ontotext and Semantic Web
Company. And actually, we bring together
two
elements of of our craft
world, which is the data community and
the content community.
I regularly have such conversations also
at CDL.
There's this
content community which is using
semantic knowledge models since years
and years.
And on the
Sorry. [clears throat]
And on the other side, the data
community which is uh
using similar approaches, but
having probably other goals in mind. And
it's always an interesting conversation
when those communities come together.
And now, eventually, I think time has
come.
And Craftwise is definitely
a company which embraces both elements
of of craft
uh quite a lot. And yeah, we've been
around for many years. And I think time
has come now.
Um coming up with a lot of experience,
two products having been used already
by more than 100 customers.
Uh so, that's 50% of 200
as a joint bundle. So, it's
doesn't come out of the blue, this
merger.
But it's more the result of a
let's say long-term trusted partnership
between two companies.
And I think time is
timing is good. So, there is a lot of
dynamics on the current on the market
currently. You can observe
knowledge graph have been put into the
center
of Gartner for instance as one of the
top analyst firms.
And we see two main application
scenarios. So, one is uh
semantic layer. So, the question is
always how can we integrate
heterogeneous data? That's exactly when
it comes to customer engagement as well
as I said before.
So, you need data in a more structured
way to get linked to
data which is rather unstructured,
semi-structured, somewhere in between.
That's the semantic layer story in
short. I will come to that in a in a
minute in more detail.
And the other element is how they can be
used to enable
genAI applications. So, we all discuss
GraphRock at this conference, I guess.
And GraphWise would like to
also explain how they can
work on our platform. That's a bit of a
different approach probably as some
other vendors may take, but you will see
it's quite efficient one.
So, why is this whole story so
important?
So, on a
quite abstract level already mentioned
it, it's this this
uh
connectedness of uh
data sources which uh trigger customer
experiences which are really not very
nice, so to speak. We all know that from
our role as a consumer, I guess. So,
from time to time you
>> [clears throat]
>> try to
get your head around a product and then
you go to the documentation, you go to
the marketing collaterals, and there's a
lot of contradiction.
They're outdated.
Marketing messages don't fit together
with what the product teams would tell
you, etc. So, it's it's I think in many
industries a a major problem.
And uh well, one of the main reasons is
it's siloed. So, all these uh processes
work in silos, and the data they produce
are also siloed.
And uh so, how can we
address that problem?
First of all, there's a strong need
that's clearly uh underlined by these
statements, as you can see.
A lot of companies try to fix the
problem. Like uh the success rate,
unfortunately, is very low.
Uh it's a huge priority.
Uh that's a very um
um a a report uh which just was
published recently.
And Gartner is also quite clear how to
fix the problem. It's really centered
around
uh
more efficient knowledge management
system,
which has to uh
be put next to the
uh self-servicing portals, to the help
desk portals. And what means a better
knowledge management system? That's of
course not a next question.
Um and I will get to that point.
Yeah, and then the other story, when we
talk about GraphROCK in general, it's
definitely very much related to to risk
management, AI risk management, as you
can see.
You
Yeah, you can
contain risk in different ways.
Uh obviously, the technical measures you
can take are one of those, and this is
what a GraphROCK can do both. You You
see a lot of organizations struggling,
and also even on a
um broader scale, we have a lot of
issues to solve at the moment with AI.
Uh
we we all know lack of interpretability,
for instance, is one of those issues.
Uh we face regulatory challenges, like
explainability is important. EU AI Act
is driving that quite a lot.
On the other side, we have, for
instance, uh
a lack of accountability. So, there's a
lot of synthetic data now around being
reused by other AI agents. And at the
end of the day, there's no reference
layer anymore. So, we don't know where
the data comes from. Nobody is
accountable or doesn't feel responsible,
nothing like that. So, it it could
become a bit of chaotic uh
uh time ahead of us when enterprises
don't do not care
about where all the data comes from and
uh
if there's a lack of governance uh
around that. That uh we at Craft Vice
believe is very important to have a
semantic layer in place, which uh picks
up that problem.
This is just one example. Some of you
might might have seen this news on
Washington Post. So, there's one uh
uh
uh vendor of a software
went public a bit too early, obviously,
with the product. This is like a
nightmare, I guess, for the people
who have done that. Um
And that's also, I think, a very
illustrative picture. If you ask a
GenAI,
an Indian person, you get these
pictures. I mean, this is exactly what
should be avoided. And it's not just
images,
it's text, it's everything what's
generated is heavily biased. And that's
a big problem.
So, to sum up, why is graph AI needed
now? So, why is this semantic layer so
important, not just for customer
journeys, which uh
are convenient, but in general? So,
first of all, um yeah, more precise
decisions should be made. Um I
frequently call it also a second point,
desktop data integration, is something
which keeps us busy.
We would like to have more time for the
actual knowledge work and not for the
looking around for all the hunting
activities, all that.
Um it definitely needs a more holistic
view on data to be able to create
knowledge-able results.
We need obviously more contextual
information to feed into LLMs, so
to yeah, produce rack systems which are
domain-aware,
so understand domain-specific
knowledge in a way that they can really
produce
results out of enterprise data and
enterprise content.
And in those repositories, you you
typically would not find domain-specific
knowledge. It's uh it's nowhere written,
it's nowhere stored.
But to bring up good answers, you really
need
uh yeah, a digitized version of what our
domain experts typically have in their
heads. So it's really
domain model which can do the trick.
Then the next one is, yeah,
explainability, trustworthiness, and
corresponding governance process to
mitigate the AI risk. So those are the
six big points
why a semantic layer is uh needed in
uh in an enterprise environment
in order to move forward [snorts]
in a strategic way and not just on an ad
hoc way. So of course, you can use gen
AI and all kind of rack systems
per silo, per applications, and you will
produce relatively good results,
but it's not a strategy. So in the long
run, uh this won't work.
So what have we in mind? What can we do
exactly to
uh address this problem? First of all,
um it starts with the user intent. So if
if you have a customer and asking
questions about your products and how
does it work, how much does it cost, and
how can I use it in this and that
environment?
It's like always a bit of problem.
Already starts.
Does the user have the right knowledge?
Can he or she express his intent really?
So, a query assistant is extremely
important on such
self-servicing portals.
And it's all the same
the case when for instance employees
should get on boarded. Let's say you
want to
ramp up your sales people or your field
engineers. They have different levels of
knowledge. So, how could they formulate
really good questions? And a query
assistant is heavily
I would say needed.
And here a knowledge model can really
help to do query assistance. You can try
that out if you like on
our website knowledgehub.eco.
So, here you will see this
query assistant.
And that's the first step. Then of
course prompt tuning would be the next
where
knowledge from the knowledge model is
retrieved after the system has
understood the query intent. And by that
it's going to be enriched
with knowledge from the background. And
here already the possibility is quite
obvious that you do it in a personalized
way. So, it really depends on who you
are. Yeah, which role you have when we
talk about for instance sustainable
financing. It really depends on if you
are rather a risk manager or an investor
etc.
What
this intent of the the same question
could mean different things. And And
this is this additional knowledge can be
injected from the knowledge model. So,
this is what prompt tuning can do for
you.
Well, and then you know the
search vector is produced and and you
can
I don't I don't I can show it here on
the right hand side you see
documents being retrieved and
these documents again together with the
knowledge model in the background are
then pushed to the LLM
which then produces uh
the corresponding answer based on your
internal knowledge and the knowledge
model at the same time.
So this is one of the flavors we offer
as a Kraftwerk solution.
And you will see in a second we have
three different flavors. This is what we
call variety number two.
Okay.
So this is a variation of that
same application
where you can pick from different roles
and as said before the
depending on who you are the knowledge
model will be used in different ways. So
it it understands for instance as a risk
manager in that case you're probably
more interested in
such aspects
which are centered around ESG risks
let's say. If you are consumer then you
probably when you ask the very same
question um you will get other answers
because
obviously your interest your intent
should be interpreted differently. And
this cannot be done by LLMs or vector
arc that nicely because it's really
heavily centered around the domain
knowledge. Yeah if if you think about
let's say an expert like a consultant in
a in a certain domain and you come and
have a question yeah to to a lawyer
let's say
um of course it heavily depends on who
you are how the answer
the answer given will heavily depend on
that. So an expert knows these
connections and this is exactly where
the knowledge model plays a very
important role to digitize this kind of
domain knowledge that you can run
personalized services like that.
Yeah, that's a very important for
customer journeys. Obviously, it depends
if you just, you know, have arrived and
you're new probably to this uh
platform. Let's say you are a user of a
of a particular car or if you if you're
an expert, you would expect different
answers, yeah, when you have a question
uh if for instance an error occurs.
Another example would be uh specifically
understanding um reports um
for instance ESG reports.
So, uh you know, as a company you are
obliged to report uh on your ESG
performance uh following the CSRD
rule set of the European Union
depending on where you're located. And
this is a really really big task, yeah,
for a lot of companies.
That's an example where you really have
to understand where you stand compared
to others.
Um and this is where uh such rock
systems can really help you quickly
understand, okay, what are the others
doing, what I'm doing, where are the
gaps. Uh and again, you need a knowledge
model for that in place where um
different repositories get connected
first hand and then in the second step
uh the system starts to understand um
the specifics of each and every
statement that you find in this ESG
report and how it should get
interpreted. So, what you see here is
really, okay, a company like Mondi
is asking, okay, where do we stand with
uh
our ESG report, how do we compare to
others, and here's uh
a list of uh elements you have to uh
comply with
uh uh following the
uh CSRD guidelines.
The next one a nice example and that's
very much geared towards customer
uh engagement and customer satisfaction.
Company out of the US called Avalara.
Um they ship
uh software and data services around um
tax.
Uh and their product uh is called
AvaTax.
And it comes in all kind of flavors, you
know, depending on where you live, you
probably would also need uh
particular answers. And this is a a
really tricky problem when you want to
provide self-service portals around such
heavily, let's say, sophisticated
product.
And so we
um showed that vector arc is just not
good enough and outperformed the
um results of of a, let's say, classical
vector arc. And we see that now
regularly at uh Craftwise. So companies
have started out to create their
applications, typically using vector
arc.
And it's most often just not good
enough. So it it's especially when it
comes to domains like
like tax. Uh you can imagine if there's
too often um
an answer given which is wrong or just
not complete enough, uh
you will lose your customers quickly. So
this is quite clear. You cannot ship
that. We've seen the example of of of
the other uh vendor in the space what
happens if you're not uh
good enough with your results.
And so Avalara chose
a different way and they were quite keen
on uh using um
their great content repository, not
losing the content structure there.
So they using DITA standard um has have
a very sophisticated content model in
place. And obviously, you should not
lose this structure, um, to come up with
the right input to your LLM when you run
this, uh, rack system.
And so, we kept track on the structure
of the content repositories, uh, built
the knowledge model around, uh, the
products of Alara,
uh, and the whole text domain in
principle. And all that put together
produced, uh, satisfactory results. So,
it's, uh,
completely different level of accuracy
now we've reached by that.
If you're interested, there's a white
paper which explains, uh, quite in
detail the whole approach. It's called
DOM Rock Graph, um, which stands for,
uh, Document Object Model,
uh, Graph Rock, where we fused, um,
yeah, the content graph with the
knowledge graph.
Then, of course, it's not just our
customers. We drink our own champagne,
also. So, we all have just recently
published our,
um, own portal for our customers, where
they can, uh, train themselves, uh,
around our products.
And it's also in all kind of
interactivity, it's interesting to have
such,
uh,
uh, self-servicing portals. Like, for
instance, when we get a new RFI, RFP
process, uh, into the company,
it's a bit of a repetition of what
you've done in the past. So, there's
like security questionnaires, etc., etc.
Uh, always the same questions coming in
different formats, different ways.
Um, and obviously, here, uh, our
knowledge repository, together with our
knowledge graph, can help a lot to
shorten time
to submit offers and things like that.
So, it's not just for customer
engagement, but also for sales
enablement, uh, etc., quite a helpful
approach uh, you can take with this kind
of uh
a craft rock. And then even the creation
of the model itself can be supported by
this principle.
Um so, when you create knowledge models
starting with taxonomies for instance
and later
heading towards ontologies, LLMs can
help the knowledge engineers
to get faster. We definitely would not
suggest to replace the knowledge
engineers with LLMs. Doesn't work. Um
so, all these automatically generated
knowledge graphs are
I wouldn't call them knowledge graphs to
be honest. It's a
kind of co-occurrence network or
whatever you want, but it's not a
knowledge graph. So, we keep the human
in the loop, but um LLMs can definitely
accelerate the process.
Yeah, and now I come to a probably to
the most important
um slide from a let's say conceptual
perspective.
Uh you see at the bottom
typically you have a highly
heterogeneous data landscape starting
from uh structured over
semi-unstructured
data, all of that, different flavors.
It's a huge spectrum.
And all of them talk about business
objects in different ways having
different facts or elements attached to
those.
And the first step really is you have
need a consistent metadata layer on top
which is obviously done automatically.
Otherwise, it wouldn't scale. And the
quality of this consistency of the
metadata is really driven by the
knowledge models.
So, we suggest to use knowledge models
to drive that process and also to create
the large enterprise knowledge graph
later. So, at the core in the semantic
layer, you really have these domain
knowledge models
um subject matter experts can
work on together with as we call them
knowledge stewards
and knowledge engineers. And this is I
hear that frequently enterprises say, "I
get the point. We need that." And
because the beautiful, let's say, chain
I applications, graph applications they
sit on top of the semantic layer. Yes,
we understood the quality is better,
everything like that
is clear. But still obviously the
bottleneck for enterprises is how can we
ever create these knowledge models and
maintain them?
Who is responsible? What is the
governance model? Etcetera. This is
still a bottleneck interestingly after
20 years of
let's say
ontology work. Um
I hear that frequently more in Europe,
less in the US. There's an interesting
gap between those two continents. Uh so
in Germany especially they talk about
terminology. They love to do
terminologies, but this is not the same
as a knowledge model.
Um and so we really suggest to look at
the numbers. I It doesn't make sense for
a large enterprise to
say, "Well, we cannot do that." It costs
a couple of hundred thousand uh euros if
at all.
Uh
and it produces a lot of value
downstream. And of course the main issue
is how to get to these numbers. And
well, it's use cases, it's knowledge.
For instance, which type of graph rock
should I pick? Should I pick type one,
type two, type three? Type three is just
at the same
moment presented by
uh
Nacho, our president at Graph Wise. He's
talked about talk to your graph. It's
type three. I just showed you type two.
And this is one of the elements. You
need to know which of those to pick for
which use case. Yeah, because there are
costs attached to that.
Um you need to understand how that's set
up from an architectural perspective.
That's again the Avalara uh use case. So
you need to create a knowledge graph,
content graph,
different ontologies, etc. So this is
the next element.
Uh
and yeah, you need to be aware of of
what's possible. So, for instance, when
it comes to
um this uh prompt fine-tuning I was
talking about before, it's a great idea
to have a kind of inference mechanism in
place. So,
in other words, you need a knowledge
model which allows you to infer from
each kind of intent query or each type
of document what's really
implicitly written there. So, again,
coming back to the to the ESG report, uh
so, some company may state uh something
like that what's written there.
So, what do you really need to know from
a risk perspective, for instance, if
you're a risk manager, what risks are
addressed by that? So, you need to know
what ISO 14000 is doing.
In the reality, it's a standard for
environmental management systems, and by
that I can address certain risks, and if
I use a standard to do so, I also
mitigate regulatory risks, etc.
So, all this knowledge for domain expert
would be probably reproducible,
but for a let's say traditional
uh text mining or traditional intent
recognition engines, just not possible
to understand that. You need to have the
domain knowledge in place.
And then, from non-financial risk,
inferring the financial risk even more
uh
uh I would say
random if you use other uh technologies.
You can ask ChatGPT directly if you
like, and it will get every time a
different answer.
So, what we propose really is for
enterprises especially, probably not the
small organizations, but anything above
5,000 employees or so,
to really start taking graph very, very
seriously.
So, it is a strategic effort. It's not
just
yeah, do a little bit better analytics
on top of one data set.
It should be part should become part of
of a bigger initiative.
Uh it fixes a lot of problems in
enterprise data and content management.
And eventually uh
yeah, bridges the gap between content
and data people
in order to produce knowledge. Because
we want to have business users and end
users and customers
yeah, just be more efficient to find
their way.
And the center of excellence of things.
First, it really makes clear all of our
organizations uh they pay every year
what we call bad
uh
data tax. Bad data tax is
what the big system integrators love.
They got rich by that. Yeah, the the
really big integrators out there
they don't like graph that much because
of that reason. Okay? I'm not naming
anyone, but you know who I'm talking
about, yeah?
Um
then obviously it finally should get up
to the C-suite. Um it shouldn't reside
at the graph engineer level or the
content manager level or whatsoever.
It's really a systemic problem we have
to fix here.
Um also we see
um
two things
have to work at the same time. It's not
a good idea to boil the ocean for 1
year, set up a huge strategic initiative
without any use cases attached. So you
have to quickly demonstrate the value.
So
both has to happen at the same time. In
return, if you just do one or two use
cases have no strategy attached, it's
also not
going a long way typically.
So it's all about communicating around
this effort
in a way that people inside an
organization start um
to get involved.
See that something I should support.
It's not just a technical effort. It's
really more an effort
to
yeah, bring the right people together in
a way that they see okay, a knowledge
graph can help all of us to make their
work better and make our customers more
happy.
And yeah, if everything goes well, it
should really convert into an an
very important URL element of our
enterprise platform.
So, this semantic layer is a very very
essential piece for the next couple of
years for a lot of enterprises.
The good news is at Craft AI we have
already quite a lot of such enterprises.
They do that. They have already
fulfilled a lot of steps. So, it's not
new.
We we can we can report on a on a couple
of successful implementations. It took
couple of months. It's not like
do it in one weekend you have the
semantic layer. But those companies will
I'm sure next year at CDL or wherever
report on the success stories.
And there will be a couple of others
following soon.
And yeah, it's it's I would not say
thousands out there doing that already.
But we reach more and more the number of
let's say 100 where companies are really
going into this direction.
So, yeah, thank you. I hope it was
interesting and sorry for
yeah,
that you didn't have a break now. Is it
now? I don't know.
Yeah, okay.
>> [applause]
>> Already questions. Thank you very much,
Andreas. Uh do you have questions?
I have one quick question. You mentioned
about being able to
generate synthesize taxonomy.
At what stage does it happen in terms of
the
enterprise customer's journey for for
adoption?
You mean that the synthetic generation
of a sorry. There was a part about
generating a taxonomy.
>> Yeah.
At what part in like a
the life cycle of adoption would a
customer be doing that?
It's it's definitely an it's an ongoing
process. So
knowledge models are evolving and you
enrich them also over time. So it's a
ongoing process really. Of course at the
beginning
you never start from scratch. So we have
a lot of standard ontologies. Yeah, a
couple of them got named all over the
places here at the conference. Of course
the reuse of existing ontologies and
even you know specific taxonomies is
definitely a good idea. Um
but
you cannot expect as an enterprise that
you will find somewhere on the web your
knowledge model. So you have to spend
some time on creating the one which is
specifically describing your business
and and and your knowledge.
Other questions?
Thank you very much Andres.